Hank: Good morning, John
First, I don't have time to analyze the whole
census right now.
I really wish I did.
And I'm going to.
But right now I don't have time 'cause there's
a lot to do today.
But I will say: That until your unnecessarily
negative campaign started, my hair was winning
handily and now, surprise, surprise, it's
losing.
Obviously this isn't a thing that matters.
It's not a big deal.
But I will say that if my hair ends up losing
it is an indictment to the entire process
of democracy.
If you look at the daily trends, and yes!
You can look at daily trends!
I love this survey, I'm so excited to analyze
it!
My hair was kicking your hair's butt, everyday,
until you made your video.
Second, book towers.
Oh.
My God.
We got so many amazing, astounding book towers.
Like, there was almost 900 book towers sent
to hankandjohn@gmail.com.
And they are all beautiful.
Some of them make me uncomfortable with how
amazing they are.
To all the people who were able to make Book
Towers: Thank you for putting your time and
effort into it.
I'm very sad that there can only be ten winners.
But that's the rule I made up.
So, where would we be without rules?
I will say though, that many of the winners
appeared to be violating one of the rules,
which is: Don't do anything that might be
dangerous.
And I can't imagine you built these towers
without standing on one of the steps of the
ladder that says "This is not a step".
But I don't have any way of knowing that for
sure, so I'm giving you the benefit of the
doubt that you didn't do anything dangerous.
Fingers crossed.
[phone noise] Who texted me?
Without further ado, though here are the winners
for the tallest towers.
We have Abby at #1 with a 483 centimeter tall
tower.
She says that no part of the tower is touching
the wall and I'm trusting her.
This one from Abby, Emma, Drew, Sue and Rob.
This one from Scott.
This one from Pete.
This one from Josh.
And we're gonna add in Steve just because
Josh and Steve's were very close together.
Choosing most styling was ridiculous difficult
because, of course, it's subjective and there
were a lot of amazing submissions.
But here's what we're going with:
We've got Heather and Michelle's Nerdfighter
sign and DFTBA.
Lauren's Christmas tree of books.
"The Arched Tower of Twists", from Morton,
"The Rocket", from Alexa Vlada.
And Abby and Katie's amazing recreation of
Minas Tirith.
Which, remarkably, was not the only recreation
of Minas Tirith that was submitted.
I had to have two honorable mentions, though.
One, for engineering which goes to Brian because
this book tower doesn't look like it should
work.
That's just really remarkable to have a three
legged book tower this tall.
And the other goes to the Nerdcrafteria Minecraft
server which had over 30 people working for
days to build this really remarkable Minecraft
book tower.
That I have very much enjoyed exploring and
it's full of surprises.
If you wanna go check.
it.
out., so you can go to mc.nerdcrafteria.com
Third thing.
NerdCon: Stories is coming up, and I recently
was talking about it and I said Cassandra
Clare was gonna be there.
She's not.
I was wrong.
I apologize.
But there are gonna be many other amazing
people there.
We've got Holly Black, Mara Wilson, M.T.
Anderson, the Welcome to Night Vale folks,
Nalo Hopkinson, Jacqueline Woodson, Rainbow
Rowell, John Scalzi, Stephanie Perkins, Pat
Rothfuss and me and John.
And more and more and more.
It's gonna be great.
Fourth.
Let's go get on an airplane!
Okay, bye.
Hank: You're never on Vlogbrothers anymore.
Katherine: How about that.
Hank: But you're on Snapchat all the time.
[Katherine laughs]
Hi.
John: Hi
Hank: John I'll see you on, um-
John: Now!